every second Apple makes 1444 dollars of
profit that's more than any other
company and almost as much as alphabet
Microsoft and Facebook combined a bank
account of two hundred and eighty five
billion dollars makes it more country
than company anyone else would kill for
pockets so deep but Apple is wary and
while most companies beg not to be taxed
countries beg not to tax Apple the
strange story of Apple's finances
explains how it got so wealthy why this
is a problem and what they'll buy next
companies pay taxes to the country in
which their money is made a toy might be
invented and manufactured in Antarctica
but if it's sold in Germany that's where
it pays taxes and because these taxes
vary by country so do the costs of
products the iPhone ten is a thousand
dollars in America but 1368 in India and
1455 and Hungary in fact if it weren't
for import taxes it'd be cheaper to fly
to the US buy an iPhone and fly back but
there's an exception to every rule and
that exception is always America it's
the only country that taxes based on
citizenship that means a US citizen
living and working abroad still owes
taxes back to the US you could renounce
your citizenship but you'd be taxed for
that too and for American companies this
means paying the highest tax in the
world on profit made everywhere so this
won't fly when Apple pays tax overseas
America subtracts that amount from its
tax rate and then reaches out its hand
this is where Apple Google almost every
major company says hmm actually I think
we're gonna keep our money out here for
now that money goes into a subsidiary a
company that's legally different but
really just a foreign bank account these
are located in countries like Ireland
and Jersey not for the cows but the very
generous tax code and Ireland's economy
runs not despite being a tax shelter but
because of it
what they lose in taxes they make back
from the jobs these big companies bring
so when the European Union stepped in
and said hey Apple you've been getting
far too fair a deal time
pay your dues Ireland rolled its eyes
and shook its head passing up on 5% of
its entire GDP but what about the 30
percent of revenue Apple makes in the US
well one way to pay less taxes is to
make less money at least on paper all of
Apple's products depend on patents and
unlike people places and things patents
have no precise value making them a
handy way to move money so they give
their patents to the Irish subsidiary
who then rents them back to Apple for a
fee when Apple makes money in the u.s.
it can wink at the IRS and say this
isn't profit we owe it to the owner of
the patent in Ireland sorry America it's
just not our money to give this is how
profit escapes its country whether it's
made in Spain or Maine and technically
Ireland taxes that money whether it
stays in the country or moves offshore
but where there's a will and 285 million
dollars there's a way if money is
transferred to the Netherlands a handy
loophole makes it nearly tax free so it
briefly flashes an a Dutch bank account
owned by a non-existent company with no
employees to take a legal box and then
it returns back to Ireland this time a
subsidiary located in the country but
legally a resident of Jersey where it
can finally retire to the cows and
castles in peace the richest meal for a
corporation isn't gold covered chocolate
or expensive caviar but an Irish and
Dutch subsidiary sandwich
all of this is 100% legal and 100%
common but because Apple makes so much
more money it's in an unusual position
no matter how big the pile grows it's
all frozen just out of reach it's like
being given the world's largest bank
account with no ATMs to withdraw from
and the problem is actually much deeper
than that
[Music]
to pay American bills Apple takes
American loans money for which it
already has just not as far as the u.s.
is concerned but it can't keep up with
how fast the pile is growing to you and
I this would be the opposite of a
problem because it's easy to imagine
Apple as a giant fat cat swimming in
money and worrying only about how to
spend it all giving away billions would
be mere pocket change to someone that
wealthy and maybe it should pay higher
taxes but there is no singular Apple the
CEOs of the CEO are shareholders and
when someone buys a portion of the
company he does so in hopes of earning
more money tomorrow than he paid today
stocks can cost pennies or hundreds of
thousands of dollars but what matters is
how much that number changes and that's
the problem
to an individual money in a bank account
is money it can use but to a shareholder
all that money means nothing if it sits
watching grass grow that's money not
being invested in making twice as much
tomorrow
the desire to minimize taxes kept money
offshore but that made it useless for
what they care about most investing back
in the business but everything is about
to change
when the u.s. lowers its corporate tax
Apple can finally bring back its money
the question now is how to spend it all
it may research future products acquire
small companies and buy back shares but
why not acquire something big articles
like this one suggest Apple by Tesla
Activision and Netflix and to an
investor this makes perfect sense
diversifying a business so dependent on
just one product and without making too
big a dent in its wallet but implied in
this argument is another if Microsoft
and Google successfully acquire
companies left and right but Apple
rarely does they must be sleeping on the
job
Microsoft just bought LinkedIn for eight
times more than Apple's ever paid for a
single company but never assumed the
world's most profitable company is bad
with money
Apple strategy is to shop for talent and
technologies never trying to make a
quick buck when it needed touch ID it
bought authentic when it needed a voice
assistant it bought Siri and when it
needed Steve
it bought next suggesting they buy
activision or netflix is suggesting that
apple's stop being Apple because
absorbing a company also means absorbing
its culture and forever changing its
most valuable asset extreme focus it's
the same reason they make so few
products and design them so minimally
saying no to what every other company
would say yes to is exactly what makes
Apple so successful if you have thoughts
about Apple how corporations should be
taxed or anything else you want to share
with the world you might be interested
in learning how to express those
thoughts with an animated video like
this one and the best way to do that is
with skill share a community of online
courses on everything from design to
business for example if you're
interested in animating your own videos
you might take a course like this one
the best way to learn is by doing and
with skill share you can practice by
following the course work of a
professional as they teach you how to
make graphics from scratch I have
absolutely no background or special
talent in design but I got better by
following courses like these and slowly
adding in my own style and I think you'd
be surprised by how affordable it is a
premium annual subscription cost less
than ten dollars a month but even better
the first 1,000 people to sign up at SK
LSH slash poly matter 3 link in the
description will get their first two
months for 99 cents you could be well on
your way to making videos like mine for
99 cents in fact if you use skill share
to start a channel email me a link and
I'd be happy to take a look
thanks to skill share and to everyone
who gives it a try if you enjoyed this
video you'd probably also like the grand
theory of Apple where I explain apples
overarching philosophy from why they
remove the headphone jack to how they
prioritize their products
[Music]